we need a whole church commission style
hearing we need a whole uh way just to
have total transparency of exactly
what's going on here because we still
are only seeing a small portion of it
and I bet you it gets more rotten more
nasty and more seedy than we could even
imagine it and right now yeah
yeah I agree uh especially with the
Congressional hearings because I mean if
his history has proven anything what we
heard fauci we know he committed perjury
we heard uh Jack Dorsey it seems like he
committed perjury we've got a long list
of people who seemingly commit perjury
in front of Congress and nothing really
happens to them so what are the
ramifications you go up there you lie
you go home everyone knows you're lying
and nothing happens yeah law enforcement
Society it's all it's all broken yep I
mean you look at uh almost every
circumstance of Street violence from the
far left unaccountable unaccount like
there's no accountability none so why
would
if conservatives don't respond in any
meaningful way
why would any cop stick his neck out